chaque année le 13 août les cloches de
la chapelle de la réconciliation sonne
comme un glas pour marquer la date
anniversaire de la construction du mur
de berlin la prière se fait avec couvert
de la ville
mais ce 46e anniversaire est marqué par
la découverte d'un nouveau document
accablant pour l'ancien régime
communiste d'allemagne de l'est celui
qui ordonne à la police des frontières
de tirer sur les fugitifs qui passer à
l'ouest
n'hésitez pas à utiliser votre arme à
feu même si ce sont des femmes et des
enfants qui passent illégalement la
frontière comme du coup même que sont la
première fois ces documents montrent que
les armes à feu étaient utilisées sans
restriction
ces femmes et ces enfants venus parfois
du fin fond de l'allemagne de l'est pour
passer à l'ouest ont donc été victime
comme les autres de la vigilance des
garde-frontière est-allemand certains
réussiront à passer d'autres pas mais
tous ont la même motivation fuir le
régime communiste et le corset de fer
que fabrique l'union soviétique sur
l'europe ce qu'ils sont repérés sont
abattus sans sommation ce fut le cas de
péter refait jetèrent bien agonise à 4
heures au pied du mur même des
garde-frontière est-allemand vont
essayer de passer à l'ouest
résultat obligation pour ces hommes de
patrouiller par deux pour se surveiller
avec ordre de tirer sur celui qui veut
traverser le rideau de fer
270 personnes ont officiellement payé de
leur vie leur tentative de fuite à
l'ouest
egon krenz ici à gauche est le seul
dirigeant de l'ancienne rda avoir été
condamné pour cet ordre de tir
il écopa de six ans de prison en 97